はぁ
[音楽]
[拍手]
うp
[音楽]
[拍手]
まぁこんないきなり変な乗り物で入ってき
ていかにもこいつについて話し始めそうな
んですがこいつ後から出てくるんで全然
すぐは話しませんすいません
はい
まあ皆さんあの竜までもないことなんです
けど身の回りにはいろんなプロダクトが
あると思います例えば皆さんが今座って
いる椅子とか僕が着ている洋服もそうです
し
窓とか乗り物とかスマートフォンとか
ゼリーとかいろんな素材でできたいろんな
プロダクトがありますそういうプロダクト
も素材ってー長い子時間をかけて例えば
作りやすいとかおいしいとかいろんな要素
で大たい一つの素材に収束していくと思う
んですよ
なんですけど今日はあえてそういうもう
ありふれてしまった素材を何かに
置き換えるってことを考えていきたいと
おもいます
はいというわけで身の回りの素材を何か再
定義してみるってことで
今日は僕が今まで取り組んできた変な素材
のものを3つご紹介します
一つはリキッドパウチモーターという変な
素材のもうカーでもう一つがセルフ
ヒーリング ui という変な素材の
インターフェイスで倍数最後が
ここにあるんですけどぽいもという変な
乗り物ですじゃあ一個ずつ見ていき
ましょう
一つ目のリキッドパーチモーターを考える
前に皆さんも立って使ったことある
でしょうか
皆さんモーターというと上に出ているよう
な軸が付いた丸いやつを想像すると思うん
ですけどこれもちろん便利ですが使って
いくとなんか重いなとかなんかかさばるな
とかちょっとあと2cm 角だってほしい
のにこの形なんか嫌だなって思う事あると
思うんですね
なんですけど実は研究の世界ではカイロで
あれば印刷することができますこんな風に
まあ市販のインクジェットプリンターとか
で回路を作る事が出来るって事は
これ薄っぺらいし軽い市矢原会しかも必要
に応じて形を変えられる
じゃあこんな風にモーターも印刷すること
ができるかっていうのが僕の考えでした
というわけでありふれたモーターというの
は金属でできているんですけどそれを液体
で作ることができないかというのに
取り組んだのがリキッドパーチモーター
です
今見ていただけるとお湯が張ってある
コップにリキッドパーチモーターをのせる
と何書く人1人で2個動き出すのがわかる
と思います
これはどんなふうにして動いている
でしょうか
実はめちゃめちゃ簡単でして皆さんパック
でお寿司とか買うと思うんですけどそこに
ついてくるお醤油のパウチにお醤油じゃ
なくて34度で沸騰する液体をちょっと
だけ入れてあげるでそうすると人肌に温め
ただけで液体が気体に代わって体積が
膨らんで動くという仕組みです簡単ですね
で簡単なんですけど実はこんなすごい単純
なものでも曲がる動きとか縮む動きみたい
なのは表現できます
これ見るとなんか頼りなさそうだなって
すぐぶっ壊れるんでしょっていう風に
見えるんですが実は力も結構出ます
今パウチは3グラムぐらいなんですけど
それでも3キロの鉄アレイを持ち上げる
ことができますこれなんてかというとまあ
日論的にはこのパウチって空気チューブが
付いてて空気を吹き込んでいるようなもの
ので実は力がすごい出せますでもそれと
矛盾するように空気を吹き込むチューブと
いうのはなくてその結果すごい軽いなので
軽いのに力が出せるということになって
ますこれ作り方も面白くて半田後体を
cnc という装置につけてこうなぞって
やると2枚のフィルムが熱でくっついて
好きな形をとることができるだからあと3
センチで学とかそういう時も自由に形を
選んで作ることができるってメリットが
ありますじゃあこの
パウチのモーター何に使うかってことなん
ですけど
例えば一つは印刷できるロボットを作る
ことができます
今入ったみたいに印刷である意味ロボット
のアクチュエーターモーターのようなもの
が作れるとすればさっき言ったように印刷
で回路も作れるのでモーターとモータを
温める田列線とセンサーと例えばアンテナ
となんとかかんとかかんとかというふうに
印刷だけでロボットを作ることができる
はずです
例えばこんな風にすごく簡単な折り紙
みたいなものとかあとは人間がタッチし
たらそれをタッチセンスして握り返しよう
なインターフェースのも秋葉原に行って
なんか武人を沢山買ってきたり知ること
なく印刷2回だけで実現できます
なんかなってますね
でまぁこのモーターチャートは何に使える
のかということなんですけれども洋服に
使った事例があります
これはファッションブランドのアンディあ
零士さんというところと六本木ヒルズれ
展示したものになりますとりあえず動画み
ましょう
[音楽]
入ってこの洋服
機能が2つありまして一つは色が変わる
機能ですこのドレス普段は真っ白なんです
けれども外から光を当てた時だけ再帰性
反射という布の特性によって色を変えつで
変えて返してくれる
さらにこの一個一個のコサージュの裏には
今まで話したリキッドパウチモーターカー
ついているのでちょっと照れてそしていう
ので温めたり冷やしたりしてあげることに
よってコサージュの形自体も変わってい
ます
この展示 alive i live って
呼んでいたんですけど
コンセプトは色即是空のドレスということ
で僕らが普段着ている服っていうのはなん
か外部から刺激が来ても特になされるが
ままだと思うんですけど
この服は服の内側の対応によって形を変え
たり服の外側の光によって色を変えたりと
いう本いうに余裕ようにレスポンシブな
洋服として実現できています
これが1個目の金属でできたモーターを
液体に置き換えたぞという例でした
次の話がセルフヒーリング ui ティっ
てこれはつなぐと機械的にも電気的にも6
時間くらいで治っちゃう変な
インターフェースです
イントロダクションとして実は僕のスマホ
バキバキになっているんですが今あの
スマホとかインターフェイスデバイスって
すごく速く正確に動くんですけど一回壊れ
ちゃうと治らないということがほとんどだ
と思いますその一方で生き物に目を向ける
とヤモリの尻尾とか人での腕っていうのは
再生することができるしきっていうのは
例えばつないでやれば次きって言って修復
するような機能があります
なので生き物の治る機能を
インターフェイスに投入したらどうなるか
ということを考えるというのがこの
プロジェクトでした
でこれを実現するためにあの僕は
カーネギーメロン大学というところに行っ
てましてそこのマテリアル工学科の人と
一緒に実際に治る素材を作るところから
始めましたいい今作っている pbs と
いうのが後で言う治る素材なんですけれど
もそこにカーボンナノチューブとかをなぜ
混ぜてやって新しい素材をつくっている
ます
これをまあ切り出してやってちょっと
確かめてみると例えば2つちぎれたものを
くっつけてやるともう10秒ぐらいで二重
を支えるぐらいには治ってしまって6時間
ぐらいでもう完全に治ります
これどんなふうにできているかと言うと
ポリボロ白木製品という素材自己修復素材
を使ってますこの素材の面白いところは
ちぎってくっつけた後特に素材を足したり
光とか刺激を足したりしなくても6時間で
治ってしまう
それが何でできているかと言うとこの
ポリマ chain を見てやるとポロン
と酸素の間に配位結合という共有結合の
特殊なパターンみたいなのがあって1回
ちぎれても治ることができます
としてもこれ見ていただければ分かるん
ですけど治っているっていうか何かとけっ
てぐちゃぐちゃになってるみたいな感じだ
と思うんですねこれを使うのなかなか
難しいんですよ
なのでそれを防ぐために tbs の中に
カーボンナノチューブの編み名を入れて
やってますそうするとをくっつけたところ
ではあるんだけどそれ以外のとかドロドロ
にならないとかあとはカーボンナノ
チューブを増やすと電流を流せるとか
色んなメリットがあります
こうやって作ったここのものをじゃあどう
やってデバイスにするかというとただ
平たいシートをつくって包んであげれば
いい何でかって言うとこれ時講習福するの
で祝詞が別にそんな必要ないんですねいた
作って積めばデバイスできます
でこれどんな風に使えるかというと例えば
任天堂スイッチのコントローラーみたいに
触ってもしくは押して動かすような
コントローラーとかもしくはなんか長い
コントローラが必要ピアノを弾きたいと
いうときにはくっつけてやればそれだけで
長いコントローラーになります
あとはじゃあスポーツゲームやりたいよ
ってなったらもう腕に巻きつけてやれば
それだけで修復して一つのデバイスになる
ので好きなだけぶん回してください
あとはと突然友達が来て4人対戦しなきゃ
いけなくなったらはさみとかカッターで4
つに分けてしまっていいですそれぞれが
まあペッ壊れずに動きますで終わったら
もちろんくっつければ元の形に戻ります
治るインターフェイスの他の事例として
これは第二の肌をイメージしているもの
ですこれは自己修復するセンサーを
マトリックス縦横に組み合わせたような形
をしていて例えば普通のタッチセンサて
触った場所がわかると思うんですけどこの
センサーはぶっ壊れた位置が分かりますで
その後検査自体は治るということは
たとえば防弾チョッキをイメージして何か
こうケガをしちゃったらこの部分に気がし
てますということを検知して例えば止血を
してあげるでセンサー自体はまた治る
みたいな応用ができると思います
というわけで時間ないんで紹介ちょっと
だけだったんですけど
ただ単に壊れる素材を治る素材に置き換え
たってだけじゃなくてそれによって例えば
作り方で接着剤が全く不要になるとか自由
な形に変えられるとかもう壊すことを前提
にしてインターフェイスを活用できる
みたいな未来が見えました
ようやく出てきたんですけどこれぽいも
っていう変な乗り物です
皆さん最近キックボードを街で見かけるか
もしれないんですけどあれ僕も結構好きで
昔は載ってたんですよなんですけど
段差を盛り上げる時に何か聞くモードが
すねに当たってすごい痛かったりするって
あとこれ持って電車とかバスに乗ると
なんかチェコでかくて周りの人に嫌な顔で
見られちゃったりするんですね7
乗り物ってちっちゃくなってもやっぱり
重くて硬くてかさばっちゃうって問題が
あります
あとはこれ僕が乗ってるバイクなんです
けれども
バイク乗った方持ったことがあるとわかる
かもしれないんですが実は結構
身長が低い方だと思っても足が届かなくて
選べないっていうことがありますなので
体格によっては選べるバイクが減って
しまうというような問題がありますうなの
でこういう乗り物にありふれた金属とか
樹脂っていうものを風船に置き換えたら何
ができるだろうって考えたのがこの恋もと
いうプロジェクトです
今ま女のご加護デューンと進んでいって
いるところなんですけれども
例えば今日も本郷三丁目とかからここまで
歩いて来られた方いると思うんですがもう
恋もがあればその必要はないですなぜなら
リュックからこう取り出して膨らまして御
山からここまで持ってくればいいからです
風船構想でできているおかげでこんな風に
空気入れがあればまあ誰でも針とでっかい
サイズまで膨らますことができてどの人が
今楽しそうに乗っていますけれども皆さん
も結構すぐ体験できてしまうと思います
なんかしら浪目してません
入ってこれがななんか危なくないんですか
みたいな疑問があると思うんですけど実は
その心配はあまりないです
これ風船とは言っても実は素材として
ドロップステッチファブリックというもの
を使ってまして板と板の間に糸がすごい
たくさん入ってますそうすると膨らませる
と普通はどんどん魂オールみたいになって
いくと思うんですが糸がそれを防いで
くれるおかげでめちゃめちゃ空気を
たくさん入れることができて思ったより
硬いんですね例えばこれももうこのぐらい
硬いんですよだから安心して乗ることが
できます
この第1世代の声もというのは膨らむから
リュックに入れられる最高という話だった
んですけどもう一個の適性としてこれを
オーダーメイドできるんじゃないかという
こともありました
でこのまあプロジェクトで行ったのは
例えばバイク方とか車椅子型というものを
起訴のテンプレートとしてそれを個々人に
合わせて好きな形にオーダーメイドすると
いうプロジェクトです
まずまぁこんな風にたくさんの物が最終的
に色も形も作れるんですけれども
8皆さん例えば築く過程にイスとかて3と
か適当にいろいろあると思うんでそれで
高校人をしていただきますでそれをなんか
パソコンのカメラとかで撮ると骨格をもと
に破綻してない中心とかがちゃんとした
乗り物が提示されてユーザーによっては
もうハンド6を高いところにつけたい
みたいないろんな要望があると思うので
バイクが破綻しない範囲で好きに
カスタマイズができます
そうすると出てきたデータは実はすぐこの
風船の業者に送れる状態になっているので
皆さんは数週間経つと個の風船が自分の
ところに届いて自分で空気を入れて膨らま
せて乗ることができるというものです
はいということで金属と樹脂でできている
のが車の常識なんですけれどもそれを風船
に変えることによって軽いとか膨らめとか
それに加えてオーダーメイドできるという
ようなメリットが得られました
はいというわけでまた最初のスライドに
戻って今日は身の回りの素材をよくある
ありふれた素材を何かに置き換えてみると
いうことをお話しましたただ実は僕のやっ
てるプロジェクトっていうのはもっと
たくさんあってここに今出ていると思うん
ですけどいろんな素材いろんな構造
置き換えるという試みをやっていますそこ
で気付いたこととして
まあ僕ってあの
あの素材用まあ置き換えているとも言える
んですけれどもそれと同時に自分自身を
着替えているとも言えます
なんでかっていうと僕文系出身なんですね
なので実はここに出てくる多くの
プロジェクトというのは一人ではできなく
てチームの人からそれぞれ技術をもらって
なんとかかんとかやっていますなのであの
まあ何でしょうね色んなプロジェクトやっ
ていくうちにあの自分自身は文系だからと
かそういうことではなくてで素材自分自身
おり定義まあ bdp に者をしていくと
いうことができると思いますなので皆さん
も身近にあるものに疑いを持って素材を
変えてみたり自分自身を変えてみたりして
くださいありがとうございました
[拍手]